let's see another example of how we can
calculate the square root of a four
digit number which is a perfect square
just like we've seen before firstly we
need to know the squares of numbers from
one to ten then we need to divide the
number into two parts we go from the
right towards the left we take two
digits from the right that is 41 and
what remains is 62. to get the 10 digit
let us look at 62. this number is
between which two perfect squares
correct 49 and 64. this means it's
between 7 squared and 8 squared the 10th
digit of the answer will be the lower
one among these two numbers that's 7.
now how do we get the units digit now in
the number the units digit is 1 and if
you observe the table then the units
digit of 1 squared is 1 and the units
digit of 9 squared is also 1. then what
will be the answer 71 or 79
for this we'll have to multiply the tens
digit with its successor so 7 times 8
gives us 56 now let us look at 62 let us
see whether 62 is greater than 56 or not
your 62 is greater than 56 hence we'll
take the larger number that is 9 so our
answer will be 79 using the same trick
can you find the square root of 8 836
share your answers in the comment
section below
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below